eu tinha seis anos de idade eu tinha
certeza que fazia parte de uma família
que fazia parte de uma organização ultra
secreta de espiões certeza absoluta não
era uma dúvida não era eu achava
então eu sabia que quando a gente no
mercado ea minha mãe a gente não tava
sonhando no mercado comprar a comida por
exemplo na hora do caixa quando ela
estava entregando dinheiro existe todo
um processo secreto um código que ela
estava entregando para a moça do caixa
que ela ia passar pelos chefs dela ea
nossa organização estaria segura e no
banco é a mesma coisa não era pagar uma
conta ou fazer um depósito
o interessante é que a mãe nunca me
falou isso e eu sabia que ela não podia
falar porque se tivesse algum microfone
escondido no nosso carro ou na nossa
casa toda segurança da organização seria
posta em risco
engraçado economia adulto minha mãe
também continua sem falar a verdade e e
isso continua na minha mente até hoje é
agora talvez até seja verdade eu acho
brincando está filmando é perigoso falar
isso aqui pra vocês hoje
mas talvez seja somente de um de uma
criança que foi criada por uma mãe
solteira e que tinha que me levar pra
todos os lugares porque não tinha com
quem deixar
então em reuniões de trabalho dela
escritório bancar o inferno infantil é é
o pior lugar do mundo porque nem ler
aqueles gritinhos e conta-poupança
bradesco era bacana saber se eu não sei
o que fazer lá
então minha imaginação ea pra fora e
pensava que eu estava vivendo uma outra
realidade ainda aquela que estava eu não
sei como é que você se vê
eu não sei se você se vê como um espião
não sei se você se vê como um herói
eu sei que a maioria das pessoas se vê
como pessoas normais certo pessoas
comuns pessoas ordinárias
pelo menos eu sei que é assim que a
maioria das pessoas que nós
entrevistamos no nosso canal chamado
marcapasso elas se vêem como pessoas
comuns pessoas não é um marca passo é um
canal no youtube onde nós produzimos
conteúdo uma parceria minha com rafinha
bastos não é um canal de humor é as
pessoas têm dificuldade em entender isso
por alguma razão é e e nós contamos a
história de pessoas comuns pessoas
normais segundo elas próprias é nós
produzimos três séries a primeira delas
é o 2 que é uma série contada através de
animação que conta a história do
encontro de duas pessoas e como aquele
encontro mudou a vida delas
então nós temos a história por exemplo
do lins que é esse personagem que está
aí que era um homem qualquer que tinha
seu emprego foi diagnosticado com a
doença nos rins têm que começar a fazer
hemodiálise entrou na fila do
transplante e estava vivendo um momento
de profunda depressão quando onde ele
como conforto tentando se forçar mudar
um pouco a melhorar ele resolve reformar
sua casa e nessa reforma um final da
reforma era colocar finalmente que a
mulher dele está mexendo o saco dele
colocar um ventilador de teto no quarto
da filha quando chega e se esse rapaz
que está instalando ventiladores de teto
e repara nos braços domingo e pergunta
pra ele lins é desculpa para que os
braços temas feridas o que é isso
o cara isso é resultado da do processo
que eu faço para purificar o meu sangue
fica explicando um pouco que a
hemodiálise pra ele
e naquele momento quem fala que ele tem
problema nos 15 está fazendo hemodiálise
por causa dos rins
aquele rapaz que estava instalando
ventiladores de teto começa a chorar na
frente dele e ele perdido ele fica
aquela sensação desconfortável um homem
adulto foram na sua frente
incontrolavelmente e no final e se
recompõe e fala meu desculpa mas é que
alguns anos atrás minha mãe faleceu por
problemas nas contas
eu acompanhei o sofrimento dela fazendo
hemodiálise
foi o sofrimento dela espera na fila de
um transplante simplesmente ela faleceu
desse problema
então no dia que ela morreu eu fiz uma
promessa sobre o túmulo dela disse que a
próxima pessoa que eu conhecesse que
tivesse problemas nos rins
eu ia dormir eu vim para essa pessoa
linda essa pessoa é você
histórias como essas nós colocamos desse
canal e
são histórias que não tem nada de como
não tem nada de ordinárias outra outro
outra série que nós produzimos com o
canal chance para tudo que é uma
intervenção urbana onde nós procuramos
tirar a pessoa do dia a dia delas e dá
seqüência à rotina diária delas estão
aqui no caso nós colocamos um biombo no
ibirapuera no final de semana e
convidamos dois desconhecidos a fazerem
perguntas uns para os outros sem se
verem
então nós colocamos um telefone de lata
pra um para eles conversarem e aqui não
tivemos várias situações interessantes
desse outro vídeo que está no canal onde
nós tivemos um caminhoneiro nordestino
conversando com um estudante de moda
lindo quando que essas pessoas e um dia
se conversar vamos tocar uma ideia é
evan falar de alguma coisa e então nós
proporcionamos em concursos de reais com
ela através do para tudo
em outra a a a minha série favorita se
chama se hoje onde nós documentamos um
dia especial na vida das pessoas e é
interessante nesse processo como disse
anteriormente que essas pessoas vivem
como pessoas como elas se vêem como
pessoas ordinárias mas não tem nada nada
nada de ordinárias nada de comum é
interessante nesse processo dedico
entrevistas e conhecer histórias e
conhecer as pessoas nós temos vários e
mails com pessoas querendo contar suas
histórias é que eu fui chegando à
conclusão de que existe muita muito
poucas pessoas normais nesse mundo
se você parar e ver se você olhar com um
pouco mais de profundidade
você vê que nós temos verdadeiros heróis
ao lado do metrô do nosso estado do
nosso lado nessa vitória aproveitando
tem uma definição porque eu gostei muito
nesses dias que diz assim que o herói é
um indivíduo comum que encontra força
pra perceber a e resistir apesar dos
obstáculos esmagadores essa frase fica
mais legal ainda quando você vê quem
disse ela foi dormir fora da lanterna
super homem
agora isso fica mais legal ainda quando
você vê que os maiores atos heróicos do
curso for livre não foi vestindo a roupa
mas foi assim
enquanto ele após o acidente ao cair de
um cavalo quando ele começou a engajar
na causa de pesquisa com células tronco
então aqui no caso está no haiti nos
estados unidos dando uma palestra a
respeito
ele fundou
duas ele começou duo um centro de
pesquisa e uma fundação em prol dessa
causa e o resultado do trabalho dele
continua perduram até hoje o herói ele
ele não espera as coisas mudar ele e ele
pega a multidisciplinariedade dele ele é
quase que em tiririca é quase que a vida
ensina coisas e e herói ele aprende com
essas coisas ele persevera ele continua
ele não pára
o fato de eu ter sido criada por uma mãe
solteira influenciou diretamente em quem
eu sou hoje como eu peço como vejo eu
acredito inclusive que estimulou
bastante imaginação porque nos deu outra
escolha
agora o interessante aqui hoje você tem
a opção de decidir como você vai ver
nessa história porque eu te digo uma
coisa se eu fosse fazer um episódio para
o marcapasso sobre a sua vida é muito
provável que eu tive isso como ela é por
causa dos desafios que você já venceu
por causa das da história da sua
história e de onde você está agora então
se hoje você pode fazer uma escolha eu
tenho só um pedido ela não queira ser um
hobby
é meu nem criança que é seu hobby e
nunca vi uma criança de volta entre fast
tinha num não seja pode vant da sua
própria história é a culpa rob em nada
contra é usem tudo aquilo que você tem
nas mãos
as suas dores suas cicatrizes
essa tal da multidisciplinar e harrad
que que a vida foi ensinando com os
desafios com as dores com as pessoas com
as traições com as feridas não somente
com a escola faculdade seja herói mas
por favor por favor meu último pedido
continue sendo você mesmo
muito obrigado